here's the next great thing about
capitalism your vote actually matters
you know a lot of countries you live in
or states you living in America there
are some states that whether you vote or
not it's gonna be Republican or it's
gonna be Democrat your vote doesn't
matter in a lot of different places
states like California or New York your
vote doesn't really matter a lot
Illinois your vote doesn't really matter
a lot right so a lot of times that
builds my vote really matter
when it comes to business it does here's
why there is no place to go complain
about a government official like there's
not a Yelp for government officials
there's not a Yelp for presidents
there's not a Yelp for DMVs no DMV cares
if you want to go out there and say bad
things about them businesses
complete different story people were
unhappy with uber you know what happens
the following month
all the people that were using uber
everybody want to who lifts because
that's how we vote you're not happy with
Starbucks coffee bean I am NOT happy
with McDonald's Burger King I am not
happy with a Jim Bally's used to be all
over the place gone LA Fitness 24-hour
fitness your vote matters and businesses
know and the reason the reason that they
know how much your vote matters they
have to treat you better because if they
don't you may be voting for somebody
else very soon